[Music]
jack
neil all right i'm going to talk to you
about
speed versus acceleration
i knew one day we were going to have to
have this talk
it's sit down
chuck chuck i need to
i need a word with you son i've been
meaning to talk to you about speed
versus acceleration
you're of age now where this is the time
don't worry there's nothing to be
embarrassed about
so there's a nice scene nice there's a
rememberable scene in the movie top gun
where they just came out of there out of
their
planes and they're holding their helmet
and what what does one of them say to
the other
as they high-five each other i've got
the need
for speed okay
i thought it was great i feel i feel the
need for speed
and i want to push back on that if i may
up okay you want to push back on the
need for speed
yes i am oh no because i claim
that their speed is
almost irrelevant to what it is their ex
their that's triggering their emotions
really
yeah yeah because for example
right now uh at our latitude on earth
the rotation of earth is carrying us due
east
at 800 miles an hour
are you saying i feel the need for speed
and this is great no
that may explain why i keep throwing up
every time every time i stand up
it could be a reason why i volunteer
so no but say see i'm about to say that
what we think of as motion sickness
is not motion sickness it's acceleration
sickness
okay okay so earth is in orbit around
the sun
18 miles per second
that all of these speeds are way faster
than anything they're doing in their
airplane
this is true so if they're not really
after speed
wow 18 miles in a second in a second one
second
from my house i would overshoot the
bronx i mean no
i would overshoot brooklyn where i am
right now you'd end up in the long
island sound
right in one second
okay so you you live in jersey
you cross the hudson river the width of
manhattan all over brooklyn and then you
come out
and i can't get up water oh my god
that's amazing
so here's the thing when you are moving
at constant speed your body has no idea
you're moving at any speed at all
okay it's only when your speed
changes that you get some
sense of motion and by
definition when your speed changes
it's an acceleration now in in my in
physics
an acceleration can be positive or
negative in
in the english language we have another
word for when it's negative acceleration
and it's just called what
deceleration deceleration okay so so i
might say acceleration
in this in my next few minutes i mean
increasing
or decreasing it doesn't matter either
positive or negative
excellent acceleration okay when that
happens
you feel it and that's what you're
reacting to
all right by the way think of velocity
okay so velocity
a change in velocity is an acceleration
but sup and a velocity has a direction
right but suppose you're banking a turn
your direction is constantly changing
well if velocity has to have one
direction now i'm changing the direction
that's also an acceleration
so here's my point when you're in a
moving object
no matter its speed if the direction
or the speed changes you are
accelerating and when you feel an
acceleration
your body is going to respond if you
accelerate forward
your body will be thrown backwards if
you s
if you decelerate quickly your body
goes forwards if you bank a turn you
lean
against the door or breaks the person
next to you in the front seat
so that's how you know you're
accelerating because your body is
responsible
responding in this way so these folks
said i feel the need for speed it's
because they're doing
barrel rolls in their plane and upside
down
and all the stuff they're doing that's
what they're feeling
but if they were going perfectly at mach
1 2 3 4 or
30 they wouldn't be saying i feel the
need for speed
because that's not anything they would
notice this was been the complaint
about the lexus car when it first came
out the lexus was a
you know a luxury car and that ride was
smooth
i read one commentary and it said it's
like
sitting on your living room couch while
you're driving your car
that sounds lovely so nobody who feels
the need for speed is buying a lexus
they want a car that can bank turns and
and go from zero to sixty
in whatever how many seconds you're
talking about that's an acceleration
yeah but it doesn't sound good to say i
feel the need
for acceleration
[Laughter]
it's a celebration of acceleration
now i just sound like jesse jackson you
know
that's what i'm saying it's because my
man rhymes anything
it comes out of his mouth celebration of
acceleration
keep alive
okay so so that's all i'm trying to tell
you
so that's why they'll they will give top
speed when you're buying a car
they will give a top speed um but they
will also give 0 to 60 or 0 to 50
in a certain amount of time so that is
the change in velocity
over a certain amount of time and so if
you change velocity in less and less
amount of time your acceleration is
higher and higher and higher that's why
they keep trying to drop
the acceleration time then it's more
ahead
it's more head snapping now right yeah
now
tesla oh because it was high right but
it'd be true for
any well-made electric car will have
very high acceleration yeah
even at low speeds right teslas can
accelerate
zero to 60 in three four seconds right
yeah yeah and i've been in it and you
can feel it it's like
yeah okay okay so now watch let's kick
it up a notch you ready i don't think
you're ready are you seated okay
all right i'm seeing okay there it is
i don't want to accelerate too fast i
better strap
it okay so if acceleration
is the rate of change of your velocity
okay so if that if you rate changes
quickly you have high acceleration
you will feel this response all the more
okay
all right if acceleration is the rate
and change in your velocity
what happens when you have a rate of
change of your acceleration
oh my goodness let me guess
your head explodes yes well
okay so if you have a rate of change of
acceleration that has a term in physics
is called the jerk
okay all right so so
watch this oh man that's great
okay so watch what happens you ready go
ahead um so
i'm headed towards a brick wall i'm
trying to come up with these
examples on the spot headed towards your
brick wall and so i should put on my
brakes
so you put on your brakes okay and while
you put on your brakes you feel yourself
you're leaning
into the the shoulder strap okay
when you hit the wall your body jerks
forward
because you had a steady slowing down of
your speed
until your speed went to zero instantly
so that is a rate of change of your
acceleration and then you feel a jerk
okay but what why don't we run
into a wall okay so the jerk
is what actually does sort of
musculoskeletal damage in an accident
okay
okay because we we can sustain an
acceleration
but when they say i have one g two g
those are pure constant accelerations
but if you go from one g to six g's in
an instant
your whole body snaps right
that's this and so the jerk is one
reverse
and the same thing reverse correct
that's so what you're basically saying
is
jumping out of a 20-story window doesn't
kill you
that's correct is it it's the
if there were no ground right he's
already fired
man so so that's uh velocity
uh acceleration and jerk
so almost every and and there's some
cars they say
in this car you can feel the road if you
ever test drive like a sports car
they tell you that right well what does
it mean to feel the road
well if the if the road were perfectly
smooth you wouldn't feel anything
so the fact that the road has certain
bumps
the lexus wouldn't feel those bumps
because the tires are adjusting to it
but your sports car which has quote
rigid suspension it is rigid enough so
that you're feeling that
all right so you and the road and the
bumps and wiggles and the turns and
twists on the road you're feeling it all
nice you feeling it and so you get so
this is what you like this is what you
seek
this is what the sports enthusiast is
actually after
even if they're not self-conscious of it
because if they only want at high speeds
you can just get on a you know
get on a high-speed train and then you
don't feel it because they're smooth
no you want to you want to bank the
turns and feel it
that reminds me of a guy on the i was on
the turnpike and a guy comes by on a
motorcycle
and he's already i'm doing 80 so he had
to be doing
a little faster than 80 because he came
by me
and then he pulls back on the throttle
and pops a wheelie
at 80 miles an hour and pulls off
okay so
and and i and i'm pretty sure he was
like i feel the need
for acceleration
[Laughter]
and with the high accelerating cars of
course a constant acceleration is a is a
one-time thing by the way
you either press yourself back or
forward or lean
one way or another and any abrupt change
in that
creates this this jolt but even if you
if you're if you're going at zero and
then you floor it there is the initial
head snap
okay that's a very high moment of
acceleration but then you stays that way
until you like hit the brick wall and
then you're snapping another way
so anyhow i just put i'm just putting
all this out there in case you didn't
know
so uh all i can say is please take
neil's word for everything he just said
let's not try the brick wall experiment
for ourselves
okay we're not responsible for anybody
who crashes the car into a wall all
right just
take his word for it all right there it
is once again chuck
you've heard it here and i'm neil
degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up
you